after months of colourful teasers and
posters Warner Brothers has finally
dropped the first official trailer for
birds of prey from its references to the
joke to this adorable hyena here's
everything you missed in the new trailer
[Music]
the trailer begins with harley quinn
announcing her breakup with the Joker
the Joker and I broke up this changes
everything for Harley including a new
haircut and a symbolic change in a tire
suicide squad showed Harley wearing a
t-shirt with a reference to the Joker
while the new Harley Quinn symbolically
wears an outfit with her name on it
identifying her as a more independent
character the song that plays throughout
the trailer is Edith Piaf's lehem alum
or or ahem to love it's an obviously
ironic choice for a song that
exemplifies the love and hate
relationship between Joker and Harley so
how does Harley try to move on by
burning down a building of course a shot
from the trailer shows hardly burning
down the ace chemicals factory location
that essentially created both Joker and
Harley Quinn and was also featured
briefly in Suicide Squad the same
Factory seems to later be inspected by
none other than Renee Montoya a
detective from Gotham City who never
technically was a member of the birds of
prey but has had a history of
accompanying them in comics and speaking
of Montoya we see some of the other
official members of birds of prey like
Black Canary portrayed by jurnee
smollett Belle working as a singer at a
nightclub and this cool shot briefly
hints at her superpower the canary cry
her ability to let out an ultrasonic
scream the cup is shaking from her
singing perhaps she doesn't yet
understand the extent of her power we
also get a better look at the hundreds
lethal vigilante played by Mary
Elizabeth Winstead the character also
made an appearance in CW's arrow and
from the looks of it it seems like the
Huntress is already very much active
serving justice with her trademark
and finally Cassandra came an assassin
who once took the mantle of Batgirl in
the comics while she was always
portrayed as having difficulty with
speech this adaptation seems to have no
trouble bantering with Harley so it's
safe to assume that the filmmakers are
taking the most Liberty with the
character the film being one of her
first live-action adaptations and for
the first time we get a look at them
together as a team the birds of prey so
what brings these unlikely characters
together the best guess is this man
Roman sionis or black mask an infamous
villain from the Batman comics while
he's a villain most well-known for his
iconic mask we never see it in the
trailer although it's heavily
foreshadowed throughout such as from
these dancers in a club or the painting
behind him during what happens to be his
psychotic breakdown but for now even
McGregor seems to be playing Roman
sionis before he becomes black masks
also suggested by these initials on his
gloves the trailer also implies that
Roman has an obsession with Harley was
going to toss me
you need we also see Harley performing
in Romans nightclub a scene that is a
direct homage to Marilyn Monroe's
performance in 1953 Gentlemen Prefer
Blondes it's also the same nightclub
that Black Canary performs in and meets
Harley
perhaps the two characters bond with
their hatred for Roman and recruit the
help of others to fight a common enemy
and perhaps the fight turns Roman to
black masks and is that when he hires
the help of zas another famous Batman
villain we get a glimpse of in the
trailer we can only predict for now and
of course it's impossible not to talk
about the hyena the trailer shows Harley
adopting a hyena from an exotic pet shop
and even reenacting a scene from the
Lady and the [ __ ] this is a concept
that first appeared in the Batman
adventures Mad Love but the hyenas are
more popularly known for their
appearances in Batman the Animated
Series what's odd is that they're
supposed to be two of them bud and Lou
named after the two famous comedians
Abbott and Costello so where is the
other one the highness aren't the only
reference to the animated series an
outfit that Harley wears in this shot
closely resembles her attire in the
episode Harley's holiday which also
features Harley firing a cork as a
weapon similar to how she fires a beam
back to knock out an officer in the film
fun note you can see various items
throughout the letters of the title that
symbolized the different characters like
this arrow that symbolizes the Huntress
Harley's hammer which can be found here
and a razor and brass knuckle that most
likely belonged to his ass so was there
anything we missed let us know in the
comments